so easy cure from the
USA has almost
24 so a matchb to exceed 24 yourself,
I think I'll take a look B6
all sorts of things can
come out of it now okay we have an
Agel
normal would now be D6 oh it's a bit
unusual actually shouldn't because of tower
D1  I'll be so precise in the
position and see if I can prove it somehow.
Although I think
knight C6 is still OK now,
I think D6 is a bit problematic because of bishop
G5,
so now I think Queen B8 will
continue  I have
no
idea, just make normal
moves or normal-looking moves, let's put
it this
way, it's really not a completely
normal
hedgehog here because of the knight on C6, the pawn on
D7. Here it's more of an issue whether Black will
move the F at some point. I don't know either
Correct how to place the pieces now
Bishop B2 e.g. he could
take here and whether that's a good
double pawn formation
H I don't
really know I could also take it myself
and
develop further well that's of course
probably pretty poor and no
advantage but I don't know either  exactly
what you do
so
D6 h you can maybe
try to go to D6 with everything you have,
double the line bishop
A3 well in the end he always has knight E8
might be a bit naive
hm yeah difficult I don't
really know W what you do either  I'll
still play bishop A3.
I can't see any other plan at the moment.
The
uprooting of the knight is a bit unpleasant. It's no
longer protected here by
the
bishop. That's why B5 is an
issue. It could be that I'm positioning myself
terribly clumsily here. Well,
we'll do it  Keep it
up okay,
I should be able to take tur1 B5 now
and then be able to take D6
so maybe he is now forced to move to
knight E8
and then I wanted to move knight D4
because it just makes
D5
good. At least now it's relatively
easy to play, you can do everything
Possible exchanges are a bit unpleasant
at the end the hole on
c3 I certainly have no
advantage Knight E5 an idea
probably not he threatens
to take it but of course he won't take it either because the 8 is
sagging Knight E5 is just B5 a
bit
unpleasant for me but okay
come play a little faster
rook  C8
maybe or do I then have knight
A4 and knight B6 such strange
ideas h yes yes that's a good move
maybe it will get out of this
pinning story and
now probably threatens to
take here
I wonder if E4 is an idea here
E4 DC knight D7 I have  too little
time, what if I still
take the rook
C3 de6 with the
intermediate dohung
no matter I have very little
time have to go a little faster
maybe maybe that's the way to
win Dr tur der8 with material or in any
case I think I have to now  somehow
react to it
like this and now I could at least
take it here and then box it here after F8
or knight D7 knight D7
is also interesting knight takes D7
and then maybe even rook
D7
pawn takes rook D8 I don't think it goes any
further, at least I don't see a
good one  Move
so here, unfortunately, he also has King
F8 which I didn't really have on the
bill.
Well, I'll take it out of here first
and maybe he can play Rook B7 instead of B8.
Yes, unfortunately I'll probably have to
take it out,
so now let's see if you can use it
active rooks here what can be done e.g.
get a third pawn I
only have 36
seconds left you already know it
t so it wasn't really correct
here with the
piece sacrifice
so of course a good move that I did
n't see either
knight F5
well I'll say that now  I don't think there's
much left and I'm just trying to use the absolute
quickest method to create any
chance of dizziness.
Yes, I don't play it very skillfully, but
it's still a
figure. Check check check check check check
check
ckck, I've exceeded the time limit and
he still has 28
hours  rettpiel at the
end yes, of course, it let in an awful lot of
air. I have
no idea that this
is here. It looks difficult. Yes, the
computer gives it
right away.
Check gives everything
the same. Yes, okay, that was of course
a reflex move
somehow. King C5 King B6 is there as the
same  and that's now, that was clear,
it must be lost somehow but
well, of course he doesn't have time t
this is
Remi again at the end comes the
hacking I was really very
fast but